My name is Maya Gans and I
am so excited to be co-teaching
the workshop web design
for Shiny developers
this year at posit::conf(2023)
I am David, software developer
at Novartis
I want to talk to
you about the workshop
we are going to give with Maya Gans
at the Posit conference
at the end of the year.
There's a lot of reasons
why I think this course is
important for Shiny developers.
But in this video, I'm going
to distill it to my top three.
The first one is
self-sufficiency in design.
Most applications,
developers work hand in hand
with designers to
create applications.
But in this course,
we're going to give you
that autonomy to
feel comfortable
in your design decisions.
And create an app
all by yourself.
In this workshop, we'll start
from the very beginning,
from the user requirements.
You learn how to deal with
them and how to translate them
into mockups you leverage
wireframing to in the end
come up with a solution
that satisfied the client.
The second skill
is user experience.
So not only will we
define what that means,
but we'll give you the tips
and tricks as well as tools
to make sure that you're
talking to your end users
and making sure that the app
sparks joy for the people using
your app on a daily basis.
In this workshop,
you'll learn how
to deal with these
kind of things.
For instance, you think
of the end users.
What does the end user want
to see when there is an error?
What does the end
user want to see
when
there is the computation?
The last, and what
I think is probably
the most important skill that
you will get from this course,
is that we're going to
be teaching these design
fundamentals such as color,
typography, layout, using
the nomenclature and code in
R. So this course is already
geared to the language
that you know and love,
and you will leave
with code ready to go.
I'm convinced by the
end of the workshop,
you will accumulate a lot
of different best practices
around web design.
So you can quickly
determine what
is a good UI, what is a bad UI.
And the good news doesn't matter
if you are a good R developer,
doesn't matter your
level of Shiny development.
In fact, it's just
about soft skills
so that you can seamlessly
translate good skills
into your previous work.
Thanks so much for
watching this video
and I hope to see you
at the conference.
Thank you so much and
hope to see you there.